[Musica]
Allora confesso fino a qualche settimana
fa il mio Ted parlava di Mario Draghi e
di come il suo governo riuscirà a
rilanciare l'Italia soprattutto agli
occhi degli investitori internazionali
scrivo di politica italiana per per
Bloomberg e questo è il motivo per cui
sono stata invitata su questo palco dal
Team del Ted
Poi però un giorno mi sono svegliata
qualche settimana fa con dolori
muscolari febbre e tosse avevo il covid
ora un'esperienza comune a molti di noi
proprio quando mi Iniziavo a sentire
meglio e speravo di avere risparmiato da
questa malattia la mia famiglia mio
figlio di un paio d'anni ha iniziato ad
avere la febbre alta
nella notte che è seguita è passata fra
Tachipirina e pezzo e bagnate però
sdraiata accanto a lui accanto al suo
lettino montessoriano non ci sono stata
io ma mia moglie che da quando nostro
figlio è nato ha assunto un po' il ruolo
che in inglese definiamo primer Parent e
in italiano mamma chioccia quindi la
mamma che gli stirerà le camicie finché
non avrà 45 anni
poi dal Ted dal dal covid siamo anche
guariti e questa storia sarebbe noiosa
un po' banale molto comune Se non fosse
per un fatto che se quella notte nostro
figlio fosse peggiorato all'improvviso e
avesse avuto necessità di andare in
ospedale al pronto soccorso mia moglie
non avrebbe potuto portarla da solo in
quanto di fronte alla legge lei non ha
alcun legame con il bambino non avrebbe
potuto prendere delle decisioni per lui
in quanto il genitore biologico sono io
ed è per questo motivo che quella notte
mentre aspettavamo che la Tachipirina
facesse effetto mentre lei era sdraiata
accanto al lettino Io invece mi sono
messa al computer che la sa che mi viene
meglio e mi sono messa a scrivere e ho
riscritto di Jet il discorso che sto
facendo questa sera
ora Provate a svegliarvi un giorno e non
avere più nessun documento disponibile
non avere un passaporto per andare
all'estero non avere una carta
d'identità se vi ferma la polizia vi
chiede chi siete non avere un codice
fiscale per fare quelle robe tipo con lo
Speed online È così che mia moglie si
sente ogni volta che da sola col nostro
figlio il che succede spesso perché
abbiamo detto una mamma chioccia e io
seguo politica eh per Bloomberg e quindi
sono spesso fuori soprattutto nelle
ultime settimane
ed è per questo motivo che questa sera
vi voglio provare a raccontare la
politica controluce quindi provare a
analizzare la politica partendo dalle
zone d'ombra
negli spazi infatti che sono lasciati
vuoti dall'intervento del parlamento che
ha il potere legislativo e di quello del
governo che ha il potere
esecutivo Infatti trovano spazio
tantissimo tantissimi altri organi dello
stato un esempio sono i tribunali e le
procure e quanto è successo a noi
infatti il nostro caso e la nostra
situazione legale non sono sempre stati
così quando abbiamo deciso di mettere su
famiglia in un paese che non riconosce
le famiglie omogenitoriali Infatti io e
mia moglie abbiamo iniziato a
documentarci abbiamo scoperto che alcuni
comuni italiani tra cui per esempio
quello di Fiumicino dove abbiamo una
casa riconoscevano atti di nascita con
due mamme
e quindi abbiamo percorso questa strada
il giorno in cui siamo andati in comune
per fermare tutte e due questo atti di
nascita è uno dei ricordi più belli più
confusi della mia vita avevo partorito
da poche ore Abbiamo fatto un'ora di
autostrada arrivati in comune io ero
confusissima della firma non ricordo
nulla ma il grande ricordo di quella
giornata è il tramezzino tonno e
pomodoro che ho mangiato al bar di
fronte del comune aveva una fame boia
dopo tre giorni nel primo passo solido
Ora anche qui la storia sarebbe conclusa
se non ci fosse un un colpo di scena nel
senso che non essendo atti riconosciuti
da una legge Nazionale questo tipo di
certificati di nascita possono essere
contestati o impugnati ed è successo nel
nostro caso quindi la procura competente
ha identificato Questo atto come non
conforme alla legge nazionale e ci ha
citato in tribunale è stata una causa
velocissima Sì ci si lamenta sempre
della Giustizia italiana per me è stato
un attimo genitore single
è una situazione in realtà molto comune
a tantissime famiglie e si chiamano
Famiglie Arcobaleno io sono curiosa
Vorrei sapere e chi di voi stasera
conosce una famiglia con due mamme e due
papà alzi la mano Dai Sofia
pochi Vabbè insomma a noi e noi
evidentemente abitiamo in un quartiere è
parecchio gay perché quando siamo andate
dal nostro avvocato per farci difendere
gli ha chiesto due volte l'indirizzo e
ci ha detto Siete sicuri che sia giusto
perché lui l'aveva già segnato su un
altro fascicolo in quanto proprio nel
nostro condominio c'è un'altra famiglia
di due mamme che sta seguendo un
percorso simile
Ora ovviamente siamo diventati amici e
noi fra qualche settimana partiremo
insieme per la Sardegna ma nel frattempo
cosa sta facendo il governo ora Vabbè il
governo se ci sarà
la risposta è poco o nulla
e non perché infatti mi capita molto
raramente di scrivere di questi
argomenti per Bloomberg e non perché in
realtà non sia l'interesse agli
investitori internazionali che guardano
all'Italia Anzi la tutela dei diritti
civili contribuisce a al fattore diciamo
di interesse per investire in un paese
semplicemente non ci sono le notizie ehm
Una delle prime volte in cui ho scritto
di questi temi è stato nel 2016 Quando
il governo ai tempi guidato da Matteo
Renzi ha introdotto la legge sulle
unioni civili e uno dei pochi casi in
cui si è approvato una legge Nazionale
che tuteli una famiglia che è diversa da
quella composta da un uomo e una donna
però ha un grande vuoto ovvero non
prevede alcuna tutela per i minori
Ho riscritto poi dei diritti civili
qualche qualche mese fa quando si
parlava tantissimo della proposta di
legge Zan peraltro Alessandro Zan è un
deputato Veneto aveva diciamo portato
avanti questa proposta di legge per
inserire una punizione per i reati di
questo tipo in quel caso la proposta di
legge è stata bloccata in Senato ora Noi
giornalisti amiamo gli scoop le notizie
ma non mi aspetto alcuna Breaking news
Su questo fronte e non perché in realtà
Maria draghi potrebbe non essere a
Palazzo Chigi la prossima settimana
semplicemente perché inserire delle
leggi su questi argomenti è estremamente
difficile anche per per un governo forte
e con un mandato politico Sono argomenti
divisivi inutile inutile dirlo
e quindi noi che facciamo Ecco noi ci
stiamo rifacendo come famiglia gli
strumenti previsti dalla legge Quindi
abbiamo iniziato un percorso di adozione
Mia moglie ha chiesto formalmente di
adottare il nostro figlio abbiamo fatto
dei colloqui con psicologi assistenti
sociali abbiamo fatto un udienza al
tribunale dei minori e Siamo in attesa
di una sentenza che speriamo riporti
presto la situazione allo stato in cui
era il giorno in cui mangiavo quel
tramezzino buonissimo devo assolutamente
tornare in quel bar
quindi un bambino con due genitori e due
cognomi
Ora siamo in Veneto che è una terra di
montagna la conosco bene perché è un
caso ma mia moglie è proprio di lì è
nata a pochi chilometri da qui quando la
sera cala il sole la roccia delle
montagne è vista controluce è compatta
si vedono solo i contorni Ecco io vi ho
raccontato la storia della nostra
famiglia perché è la nostra storia è una
scanalatura scavata nel fianco di questa
montagna nella roccia l'ho illuminata
Per questo vi lascio con un pensiero
Provate a immaginare Qual è l'impronta
unica che voi la vostra storia le vostre
famiglie Stanno scavando nella politica
italiana Grazie mille
[Applauso]